this season on direct from we're in the
Palestinian town of nebith Allah we
travel to the occupied West Bank right
across the road over there is the
illegal Israeli settlement of Hannah
nice to meet the teenage girl who's
become an icon for Palestinian
resistance loose Kenneth Medina Ishmael
your skin ethnicity and we go to Canada
where indigenous activists and water
protectors are fighting for their land
how far are you willing to go see my
blood not too soft territory and
fighting for their safety it flashed
through my mind that it could be a body
that we were trying to pull up they come
across remains and you don't know if
they're human or not or if they're your
sister the Marches to send a message to
the men who prey on them that they're
being watched by the community so you
feel like they don't deserve it
I'm gonna put the camera down okay okay
you actively
minhwan jepty higher until vent to draw
bwaha Gundam salamanca hemolytic anemia
beam
mascoutah Sangala in no daman al-kabun
Simula make sure to follow the direct
from playlist on YouTube and subscribe
to a G+